what I want to ask you guys both in
relationships
Attractive people successful people
young people if there can if you can
kind of pinpoint uh real life red flags
and real life green flags that you run
towards you too Natalia what would they
be you want to go first I
so something that I would consider a red
flag just right off the bat is well the
thing is the current relationship that
I'm in now we didn't play any games with
each other I think the first day that we
saw each other we were just hanging out
as friends because we were abroad it was
a group trip to Colombia everyone flew
in from different places uh we had
Colombia we were just talking and
hanging out as friends and I realized
that I really liked his personality and
there was a physical attraction there as
well obviously and we hit it off but
we've been together since the first day
we met like I don't we hardly have been
apart since the first day we met and we
prefer it that way so I'm this isn't
gonna apply to everyone because everyone
likes to play their games or whatever
some girls are going to be like but I'm
a Sagittarius I have to play the game
whatever
um I off the bat I like people that
present
immediately the way that they're going
to be for the rest of the relationship
so obviously it's going to be something
that's going to be very hard to gauge
but if I can tell right off the bat that
you are a family man that you are going
to be loyal that you are an open book as
far as let's have a conversation let's
set boundaries like what bothers you
what bothers me what are the
expectations that we have for the
partner and ultimately a green flag is
someone who has respect common like
human decency treats other people
um with respect obviously when I date
someone I'm looking for my husband I
don't date just a day I'm dating to
marry because that's just the way that I
am and I see all of these qualities in a
man then obviously that turns me on to
them like uh for example my boyfriend
has a great relationship with his family
it's it's adorable like he comes home
and like he's hugging his daddy's
hugging his mom he's hugging his sisters
all of that stuff I noticed right off
the bat that all of my boyfriend's
female cousins would call him Fred
advice because he'll just sit and listen
and give good advice and and he's
someone that just makes people feel
comfortable in their own skin
um and since your partner obviously is
going to represent you or at least a
large aspect in your life if you just
have the same
um morals have the same basically bullet
points for life then that's someone that
I could see a future with because I
would consider myself the kind person
who's listening and would love to give
you advice or help wherever I can I'm a
very affectionate person I love my
family I treat everyone with respect if
my partner does the same thing that I'm
comfortable making them an extension of
me and that's kind of just two follow-up
questions real quick what's the age
difference in you and your boyfriend so
he's actually the smallest age
difference that I've ever had I've gone
all the way up to like 16 years of an
age difference but he is about to turn
26 and I'm a strong 21 like five years
age difference yeah so you've gone up to
16. yeah yeah okay me too
um
the um and then the second question is
you you just kind of glossed over it but
you said that you're dating for marriage
yeah
is that always is that a new thing for
you you're 21. I don't think that's most
girls are dating for marriage at 21. do
I have that wrong the reason why I'm
able to
um be the caretaker of my of the men in
my in the relationship and then also
manage my business is because I'm very
good with time and I think that my time
is very precious because I've seen what
I've been able to build in such a short
period of time in two years I built an
empire for myself and it's great like I
could probably welcome a kid in today
and that kid's gonna be chilling
um so for me it's kind of just like
maturing is realizing that it doesn't
matter how successful you are if you
don't have someone to share with or if
you don't have an anchor because there's
going to be a lot of people in this
industry in this world that are going to
do everything in their power to at least
make you think that they're building you
up and then the second they can pull the
rug from you they will
um but having that one person that you
can turn to and rely on for the rest of
your life is key to me I am someone who
believes fully in monogamy and part of
me also is more stable when I have a
stable relationship because I'm not
dating so I have more time in order to
focus on my craft and focus on building
my relationship
um I'm not someone who really enjoys
dating either I've I'm never single
either and I always get into like the
longest relationships too which is crazy
I was single for three months before I
met my boyfriend and then I kind of like
moved in with him instantly and things
are going so good yeah well the the
reality is no pretty girls ever single
she's either with a boyfriend situation
exactly there's another guy that's
hollering I get it Jordan we talked
about red flags uh green flags you moved
to Miami two years ago different
lifestyle than Fort Myers you know that
well I was living in La for a short time
before I moved to Miami for two years
but yeah so you were living in La so
even even more of a point yeah as far as
red flags go uh Miami city of gold
diggers same with LA and bbls that whole
thing
um what alarming red flags you're like
oh man I got money now I'm on YouTube
these people see me are you like yep
okay cool red flag no no no I agree like
all right cool like what have you what
are you seeing yeah I think it's a
couple of different things
um for me I think the biggest thing is
respect you know you could take somebody
out you could see how they are just by
how they treat the waiters how they
treat the people at the door how they
treat people that you're interacting
with your friends your family if you
can't show love to the people close to
me we're never gonna work out because
I'm always around my friends what's
crazy is girls say that about guys I've
never heard a guy say that about a girl
yeah girls always say if you don't treat
the waiter knives you're not I've never
seen a guy say that so respect on that
yeah because you know you want to be
with somebody that's not an [ __ ] like
you want to be with somebody that's cool
and respectful and like she's a pleasure
to be around the other thing too is like
if they get to talking about their past
relationships and their exes and stuff
like that and it's all bad oh this guy
he oh this is the worst oh this is so
bad it probably gives you a little idea
about them too
yeah exactly so for me that's a huge red
flag
um lately now that my Channel's been
growing and stuff I like that I've been
in a relationship now for a year but
prior to that like if people already had
known me before or like we met through
like Instagram or something like that
that's hard for me to be like Oh I'm
gonna wipe her up I'm gonna take her
seriously because it's like maybe
there's another intention there so
that's something that I didn't have to
worry about now because I'm in a
relationship but that's one of those
things that was on my mind so if you
like that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire saucecast click right here
thank you